okay hello everyone we are doing an
awesome language design review about
leader data I featured long bin and
wolfen Alpha and we are trying to
kind of streamline it enough to put it
into the language
so
right just up front like I said in the
notes the the names of entity types and
names that are being used transities are
not at all preliminary and not at all
thought to be good things but they're
descriptive at least of what they're
what they represent I and I think we
just we want to talk a little bit about
the overall schema and ways that these
things are being represented but also
kind of what we're calling these things
because the idea ultimately is not that
you know the problem we're trying to
solve is not just how do we represent
leaders of countries in the language
it's how do we represent
any person who has held a position
within an organization that could be a
government organization it could be a
private public company anything else
for a specific
um tenure in that position does LinkedIn
canonicalize
um
uh
you know position titles in any way or
is it free form I think it's
pretty freeform they may suggest some
things I mean we've seen this with other
sources of data for um
uh corporate Executives where some some
sources do some level of trying to
canonicalize you might have someone
who's the
whatever they're the chief imagination
officer but really they're in charge
they're a marketing executive right the
standardizing those kinds of things but
not not everybody yeah not everybody
does that will yeah hopeless I mean you
know just like somebody could be a grand
visier in a company or something right
the
um
okay all right okay so organization
position type
well I mean what we just said makes it
sort of seem hopeless because you know
what happens to the chief imagination
officer
does the chief imagination officer get a
tag of this type or they merely a you
know a c-level executive or something
and then the rest is free form
they could be I mean I you know I we're
kind of jumping straight to an edge case
like most most people certainly people
within government positions tend to be
easier to standardize because you want
to have sort of equivalent things across
different governments
within companies people want to have for
the most part
standardized titles because people want
to know
well it'll move between companies who
kind of want to know things people get
cutesy about it sometimes but yeah I
know but I mean look I I don't
understand in the case of countries yeah
they're uh
probably some you know like a CEO is a
concept because it has it's you know
part of the API of the company is
ultimately there's somebody in charge so
to speak right right and um you know the
CFO similarly ultimately there's a
person responsible for reporting certain
things and that's part of the company
API
but some of these other things are not
similarly with countries I think there's
ultimately you know somebody has to you
know sign for the country or whatever
right and
so there are sort of API compatible
positions then you know I know in
England I don't know they're positions
like I think there's one The Keeper of
the wool sack which is some kind of
parliamentary position which surely
doesn't exist in any other country I
can't remember what note it meant
but um
I mean we could we could very well have
a lot of those kinds of things that our
organization and and Country or
government specific but that we also
they
they must fit into some kind of category
somewhere like there's a level there's
some level of yeah generalization we can
do you know somebody somebody is there
they're a legislator they're uh they're
a cabinet I agree I agree or a c-level
executive for example right exactly yeah
right but I mean my point is that the
actual name of the position you know
Grand poo bar of whatever
could be as free form probably as the
human name
that you know what we could do
is have something where we allow the
possibility of having a grand poo bar
um
uh
you know type title but we also have
this kind of canonicalized
position type right
for a particular right for a particular
person for for someone where we're
representing
this person in this position with this
organization in this time
that would be associated with a a
general a standardized type but they
might also have some property that is
the free form yes name which would not
which that that name you're not going to
canonicalize all of those things but we
still want to be able to display what
the name is exactly okay yeah that makes
sense
all right
what happens in the world of the future
I'm sorry I I just can't avoid this kind
of question and the world of the future
where we have you know transgender
monarchs and we have a king and we have
a queen and then we have to have a a
um you know a a
non-binary I should have said non-binary
when we have a non-binary what on Earth
does one do then
we probably don't want to you know this
is the point that this particular thing
there's an API it's the Monarch whether
the Monarch is non-binary or not it's
irrelevant to the API
if I'm making sense right I mean I I
these
these kinds of titles don't have
anything to do with I mean gender gender
and things like that will live at the
level of the person not at the level of
no I realize that but as soon as you say
King yeah I'm just I'm just saying most
of these are non-gendered
that one too that's that's true
uh but but I know also I'm concerned
that any given King is probably you know
King
you know
ogunog of the such and such such and
such and then probably has you know
titles that go for two lines
you know
conqueror of the such and such Etc et
cetera et cetera et cetera et cetera
it's true
but I mean that
look these are sort of API level
you know there is a role like a chairman
of a board has certain external API
functions so to speak
um
yeah
see I worry about a title like you know
then there's kind of cheat titles like
Senator and you have some you know High
School debating competition or something
where somebody gets that title
why is this a
how how does this enter into the picture
for us well because I'm thinking that if
we start picking up
who are all I see because that then the
organization to which that of which that
person is the senator then becomes the
high school thing not the us or
something yeah right
these these these things are independent
of any connection to a specific question
okay but each one of these defines some
kind of
is sort of intended to be an API
describing thing
yes
as opposed to the actual name on the
letterhead so to speak
correct
okay okay I understand okay so then
there's the status
which and again these are this is just
kind of stuff that has been pulled in
without trying to think about how we use
it from leader data where we've we've
applied these sort of tags which really
only serve uh
I think Rodrigo Cesar like they they
have only really served uh
a purpose for the visual representation
in Alpha where we've we've got someone
who's in a position and we've we've
wanted to say they're not
they're not really the full official
thing so we slap an acting tag on it and
some of these I have no idea when
they've even appeared they're odd things
throughout history yeah I'm sure they
can appear I mean you know an interim
CEO an interim prime minister a
uh these all look quite reasonable to me
I mean there's a calculus of these
things
presumably
you know can you be a resigned retired
Regent
maybe yeah I'm not I'm not not sure
where those would fit into what we're
describing because the you know the
can you be a deceased interim
that's why I'm saying I'm not sure where
how these have actually been used in the
past I mean I things like
interim elects acting
like these are things that can be used
to describe this
more precisely
the status of a person's position
at any point in the past like someone
was the interim
Kuba from 1984 to 87. someone was the
acting vice president but they you know
if you're deceased it's pretty
open-ended I don't think status I don't
think you can be an active price
whatever I think the sea still
necessarily said here I I think I think
some of these are just they they may
have been useful tags and we they just
ended up the only one that looks wrong
here is deceased because
I'm not what would retired or terminated
like if they're retired then they're not
they didn't actually
well they could be an Emeritus something
or other
right that's a perfectly reasonable yeah
you're right you're right
fair enough
um
okay so then and there
it's not just like they are no longer
in that position they they have that
position but that's an additional right
I think you know somebody yeah Brigadier
General even if they haven't been in the
military for 40 years or something
right so that is a position
that they have but it is retired so to
speak I think
I just don't know if we would we would
represent that in what we're trying to
describe like if someone was Brigadier
General from X to y
we have something that says
so and so was greater General from X to
Y then do we have another entity that
represents them as retired Brigadier
General from I don't know then until the
end of their life deceased or general no
but I think you know you can be an
Emeritus Professor sure and you can I
think you can quit being an Emeritus
professor
it's not a lifetime
you know I mean can can a university
terminate somebody from being an
American Professor I don't really know I
mean if there if if
yes that's a position in America's
Professor sorry as a position
and in fact Emeritus may be more
relevant than retired because retired is
more of a
uh I mean Emeritus is actually a a
maintained position you know the
Emeritus chairman of some company or
something I think that's that's what I'm
after like if if the
anything that just says I used to be
this thing yeah that then it doesn't
make sense if it if it means I still
retain some of the
Privileges and responsibilities or power
whatever of this position okay then it's
like the qualified right organization
position type means the vice chairman
those are really common right
oh there's that I mean there's there's
many more things that need to be in here
this is just trying to work a manageable
scope at first okay all right yeah
uh see
organization position then this is this
is the combination of
position with a specific organization
so this is where you have
you know I see a specific Center senator
specific president
wow
what happens when it gets down to you
know
High School uh you know parent
you know parent Association president of
some random High School somewhere we
definitely don't want an entity for
every single one of those do we
um I mean
surely we want to have that fear
theoretically we could because I mean
that's the other thing like
um
certainly this data wouldn't be easy to
come by for all these things but it
would exist somewhere like that the link
to that info box for president of Italy
you know the the specific any any given
position within an organization
there will be some other set of things
like who power how are they elected or
appointed to the position you know what
is what is the standard term length
what's the salary what's the right but I
mean but it seems to me that rather than
having a single entity here that we
should Factor Italy president type thing
rather than
or is that wrong
um
I mean look are we really going to have
district one two three four five
whatever it is
that seems very crazy I mean we don't
have
and what are and I'm not trying to argue
the point but then what what is the
representation of the thing I mean we we
can have
similarities of things but you know get
I'm just as we were talking about this
recently the point was
for most of these kinds of things there
are
there are properties that are that can
be specifically associated with these
combinations of an organization in a
position within that organization so
like Louisiana industry of getting to
the list of people who have held the
position but but I mean you're saying
that Louisiana three rep District 3
representative or something might have
different properties from a New York one
because you know laws are different
there or something
is that what you're saying so this is
not compositional that it's just a place
a representative
do we have a I mean New York district 18
do we have an entity for that sure
so we have okay all congressional
districts yeah
but so
I see
who I mean does that cause us I realize
like that the scope is potentially very
large well but but okay but it could
also be the case
that
um
uh
you know from New York district 18
representative one of the properties
should be what thing are you
you know what what thing does this
position relate to
answer New York District 18. right
that's I mean that's that's the bullet
point that's right below where your
cursor oh okay there should be there
should be other properties here this we
we're just talking about this this
wasn't exposed before last week and we
were saying uh this seems like something
that we should consider
having directly and that's talking about
it well that's position type but where's
Italy here
it's not that should also that's what
I'm saying it should there should be
additional properties for whatever the
Associated region organization whatever
I mean these very long entity names so
what are these These are
this is that's an organization position
tenure right it's the
the organization the position the person
and the specific period
because you could have uh I never
remember who the
presidents and well anybody who's had uh
sometimes yeah like Putin
sure
yes you wouldn't want to have a list
that's just
right I mean just in terms of visual
appearance oh yeah the better way to do
this
um maybe make this at least at least
this we more easily paused if this was
somehow smaller or something like that
I mean we could we could we could use
through the dates as
uh let's
enter anybody what's what's the the
extra field that we use where we have
the gray tags like the sense tags or
Style
yeah sub labels we could do that we also
could you know just to simplify this
because
the specific dates
aren't necessarily significant unless
it's it's a very short tenure we could
also shorten these to just kind of
year to year or month year to month year
I'm not sure the full date spec is
that useful for kind of understanding
what you're looking at in all these
cases
yes I agree except that
oh no that person okay yeah
no I mean that there might be one
I think somebody who's in office for a
day or yeah but but becomes bounced that
they were in office for a day out of
office for a week in office for a day
that is a such an unbelievably Corner
case right
that I wouldn't be too upset by having
the visual appearance just say 1955 to
1962 or something and then if that's
1955 and they were in office twice in
1955. in that same position well Corner
case right well I mean if there's
somebody in between they're gonna
they're gonna be separate entities right
you're gonna have a separate one of
these to represent each no I know I know
I know I'm saying in terms of that the
visible name yeah the fact that it says
1955 but both of them I think it's such
a corner yeah
I wouldn't worry about it
I wonder whether they'll even be a
single example of it
in the same position so to speak yeah
yeah that will definitely make it simple
to just have the the um right
uh
I would also argue that that one of
these could be italic or something like
that like the position name could be
italic then the person's name yeah I
don't know what something no we can't we
go to good design and talk about some
different whether we can Factor those
out in the names and get some different
styling
jurisdiction is a horrible name yeah
like I
because they're going to be positions
where it's it's not necessarily that you
have
it's what are you the lead yeah
area of influence or something like that
spear
yes fear of influence is probably better
yeah but I mean sphere of influence if
you're the chief imagination officer or
the grand visier of of the um
uh whatever of a company
who knows what the it's um
um
I mean almost domain
well that's right I mean that's what I'm
kind of wondering when you get into
cases like
I'm Secretary of Education Secretary of
Defense or you know
Chief marketing officer or something of
the United States
so what is the United States in that
case
it's not the jurisdiction it's the it's
the um
it's more like the entity but we can't
use that word
um
leadership well it's also I mean that
they're also you know in charge of
they have some some responsibility for
the Department of Defense but also more
abstractly for
the yes of like a specifics yeah
there'll be people who report to that
position right
but there is also
yeah what is the domain of
responsibility of the position
I mean domain of responsibility
what are you what are you thinking I'm
thinking that this jurisdiction becomes
domain
um
and then
there is a different property
that potentially represents
you know
LED organization so to speak which could
be Department of Defense in other words
the domain will be United States
the lead organization would be
Department of
um
uh
Department of Defense
see what I'm saying
yeah so for example Chief marketing
officer might have a domain that is the
company and a LED organization that is
the marketing department
um
the chief imagination officer might have
a domain that's the company and a
department of zero
yeah it's purely imaginary for example
sure
um
so okay
I mean because most positions will say
it is a it is the
Chief Financial Officer of blah blah
blah
okay what are we going to do with
companies I mean there's a zillion
companies how are we going to get
which change their names and have
different tentacles and so on we're not
going to smoosh
the um
you know CFO of General Motors
this time I guess we have to I mean in
this in this time we have to because if
I mean if a company changes its name
you're not you don't want to have
something that represents
someone in the past with CFO of a
company that no longer
okay it's in the way it did then what if
the company I mean which happens with
companies mostly within countries what
happens if the company changes its name
but the person continues to be CFO
there well
what would LinkedIn show they would they
would probably have a break in their
resume there wouldn't they I don't know
all the people
what do they show on their linkedins
I bet that that shows I bet what
happened did they just Richard well it's
whatever Elon told them to do I don't
know but they just retroactively
change their history to X um yeah I
think what happens is that the company
name canonically changes and that
changes all the history
if that makes sense
no there's nothing that says it was
you know Facebook for example then it
gets renamed meta
and um
you know it doesn't show as
cxo of Facebook then cxo of meta it just
changes the name from
you know even going back before Facebook
was called meta it changes that name
which is probably what we should do too
oh my This is complicated
well that's our excuse for waiting a
decade to get it done
okay
so so wait a minute so let me just
understand
uh
did I mean we've got all these and these
entities have been successfully exported
into the language here we've got
thousands of these things right right
yes
there are there are many more that could
be because we also have the case with
the existing leader data in Alpha where
we have we still have a lot of
quote unquote leaders who do not have a
corresponding
person entity
more historical people because the
sources were you know
just have lists of names of people and
we've we've filled those in and tried to
align them to existing people and added
people as we go
and we've been doing more of a pass to
try to
match those up and where we can't match
them up we're just we need to create
person entities even if the only thing
we can definitively say about them is
they were they had this position with
this
country so you're saying we have an
entity for you know King of the
scythians or something these states but
we don't know who that was or well we
have a we have a name we know we have
it's King whatever red or something
right but we don't have
exactly
because we know nothing about Fred other
than that he was King of the scythians
or something correct
but at this point I think we're we're
we can do a little bit more to try to
match those people up and see if we can
find more data and if we can't then we
say you know
we definitely don't have someone lurking
in people data who we've failed to align
to
um so we're just going to create an
entity for them and you know they'll
have a name and we will know that they
were King of the scythians from these
dates to these dates and that might be
the only thing that we can show about
that person entity but that's okay
yeah I think so
um
okay okay
all right so then
I mean I'm a little concerned about
things where the title you know I'm sure
when Napoleon showed up in France His
official title was different from well I
mean you know and the you know
the CEO of France was at one point a
king and later on a president
and probably went through some random
weird stuff
at some point right
but if we want to know
you know let's say we ask a question
like how old was the leader of France
you know at what age were leaders of
France sort of installed through history
I mean this again comes back to the the
API question there is a person who is
who counts as the leader
there might or might not be a person who
counts as the minister of information
let's say correct
and so there'd be specific positions
that on a country by country
organization by organization basis we
have to say this is
whatever in this period the emperor was
counts as the leader you know those
other kind of higher level
position types in this period it was the
president in this period it was the
whatever so we've also yeah
I mean in the Linguistics of alpha we've
also had these kinds of issues right so
I mean yeah to me
what we're coming back to is
there is an API level position
you know who is the chief executive of
law could be a state the governor
could be a country
it could be an emperor could be a
whatever
um
you know that's a pretty well-defined
thing
perhaps there is a second fiddle
of the chief executive
not always true
right right for for countries it's
usually true
um
I mean it's also it's another thing at
the organization position level that can
be described which is for you know where
does the
Vice Puba sit within the hierarchy of
positions in this yeah if it's known and
if they've even defined it I mean you
know in some places
they're not going to publish their org
chart or people would start shooting at
each other
no but in many in many cases there's
there's a there's a chain of command and
report and related responsibilities that
we can represent
yeah LC on our live stream comments that
there are some roles defined by
legislation absolutely right so you know
in the U.S companies have to have a
president a Treasurer a secretary I
think
um
I wonder that's also yet another thing
that can be a property of the
organization position like what what is
the legal statute or document or
whatever else that that defines yeah
that's right that's a good point The
Possession the Constitution for example
or whatever right
and presumably
should know this but this is a piece of
American what is in a U.S state what is
the analog I mean you know the the fact
that there's a lieutenant governor and
this and that and the other for a state
must be defined by some sort of
constitution of the state type
documentary States constitutions oh yeah
okay thank you
I've only lived in this country for I
don't know what 40 something years
um
uh
okay
so
um
right so that's a good point that in a
sense every company in the US for
example has
certain is you know there's kind of a
stem cell for every company which is the
thing that you have to file with the
Secretary of State in whatever state the
thing is incorporated I assume they're
awesome I don't know whether with
respect to positions and I haven't a
clue for companies in other countries
I don't even know I don't know for even
for a UK company I don't even know what
what positions are mandatorily required
um
okay but I think what we're what we're
learning is
there are
you know like for instance
the you know for many purposes the
see again it relates to this API
question there are many purposes for
which it's important to know who is the
chief executive maybe it's important to
know who is the chief money person maybe
it's important to know who's the chief
of computer security person
these are all
kind of you know it used to be the
webmaster type thing
oh boy
well I'm I'm just
I see so so there is potentially another
kind of thing here
which is
the regulatory defined organization type
in other words
it is a U.S company
therefore it has a listener this and of
this
it is a you know that that seems like a
worthwhile thing to have
and perhaps in some cases I'm sure the
UN and the World Bank have certain kinds
of you know if you're standing up a new
country
there are certain positions that you
need to if you well you're not going to
be a member of those things immediately
but presumably if you are a member of
those things there are certain elements
like if you're a member of the UN you
presumably have to have a un
representative
I mean so that's a different
thing which is you've got an
organization and like it's a member of
the
um
you know International
telecommunications Union
I'm quite certain that you have to have
a representative
for that
organization from your country
so to speak right yeah
and
yeah I mean there are things which are a
little bit fuzzier like like Chief
computer security officer
which is
you know for which people sometimes ask
for you know who is your blah blah blah
that one is not I mean that one is sort
of a fuzzy one in terms of
of um I mean you know people who are
pitching one on things will say you know
who's your chief who's your Chief
photocopier officer or something that's
kind of passe these days but you know
that that was the thing back in the day
um
you're talking about things where
someone isn't doesn't have that
as a specific that's not their official
title but it is a role that they
no actually I'm not sure different thing
no I was I was I was yakarating on about
about okay
uh weird cases okay
um
but I think for our purposes
you know the question is what are you
going to want to compute from these
things
and
you know sometimes it's very well
defined like
like you know you should be able to look
up
uh
you know I've got this bill it was
sponsored by this person here is there
and you know here is the entity
associated with that person in that
position
I mean that's an interesting case
because let's say it's a bill sponsored
by person X
they can only sponsor a bill if they're
in a certain relevant position
presumably right if they just got thrown
out of Congress or whatever they don't
get to sponsor a bill right
on the other hand that bill
I don't know I presumably there's a
moment at which they submit it
as sponsored and then it may come back
again multiple times even after they are
in a different position so to speak you
know they get re-elected so to speak
although that for us is still they they
could get discontinuously re-elected
but I mean the submitter of the bill is
a person in that position not just a
person presumably right
well what other things are we going to
want to compute I mean then we're going
to want to compute all kinds of network
type things
like
uh
yeah here's a question yeah it's a
question what are we doing with family
relations
trying to figure out what to do with
family relations what's that I said
we're trying to figure out what to do
with family relations
they're not they're not represented
in a very
scalable way right now we just kind of
we have
parents and siblings and
children but you know there's other
kinds of relationships and again like
decorators on those connections that can
be significant
right and we don't have we don't have a
way to sort of explore the graph of
things efficiently but so so for example
here's an example of something that we
should be able to do given leader data
and given in family relations data show
the graph of the relations between the
you know kings and queens of Europe type
thing
sure I mean there's all kinds of things
you want to look at the look at the
the sequence of 10 years in a particular
position or in positions across a range
of countries and look at how often
people winning out of office we should
have more political party information
associated with
leaders and matching that up to economic
Trends and other kinds of things
I mean following individual people and
their connections to other people within
other kinds of organizations government
and otherwise there's there's a
lots of connections to other domains to
to work with here right okay so I mean
like the distribution of times in office
of
I don't know secretaries of State for
example sure
should be a trivial thing to figure out
right
is it right now
I don't thinks I don't think we have
enough I don't think we have everybody
pulled over from leader data yet
I'm not sure we have all of the people
who have ever held any of the positions
we represent in this framework right now
except for maybe some things like
presidents of the U.S and some
high-level things
all right what other things do we have
to resolve in this meeting I mean this
looks like it's going in a reasonable
Direction but it seems like
um
I mean
no that's good I mean I I for this for
this one I think just wanting to get
this in front of you and have you
thinking about the structure and just
saying
yeah all right well naming and naming in
general this looks like it's going the
right way we can we can continue to put
some more things in
um Leroy has just started to add and I
think Lisa was helping to work on some
of the parsing for some of the things
related to
companies we don't have enough there's a
couple of examples of companies and it's
not enough to really explore how that's
going to work but some of these
questions about
specific positions versus sort of
generic
levels and types of positions
I think we're going to be able to get
some more examples in so we can talk
about what that let me just mention a
can of worms okay co-ceos
okay
how do we deal with that
we just put two people in or maybe
co-presidents of countries for all I
know I don't know if that's ever
happened
um
well but then they
maybe if they had exactly the same start
and end dates and one of them didn't
assassinate the other one well
this I know or
would they would it need to be something
that's represented again as
two separate
well I mean to see why it wouldn't be
too separate
it just happens that there isn't a
uniqueness just like there might be you
know five
uh Congress people from such and such a
state or something sure I mean if you
were doing a lookup for the president of
whatever country from date to date it
could very well return to people
there'll be two separate leaders who
have you could return zero yeah of
course in chaos and nobody was in charge
right
I I believe Boston has uh three
presidents that rotate something like
that
[Music]
um
you mean rotate as in unsuccessive weeks
or something or what and months or years
that's something I don't know I remember
when we did um data it was a long time
ago
well I mean didn't didn't that was the
only case have people who were in for a
day
sorry didn't ancient Athens have have
people who were like in for a day
they rotate through different different
people who uh kind of
I thought they did I feel like Lisa
wages should be
yes
um it sounds familiar but I'm drawing a
blank on the specific practice
I don't think it was the archons
no basily archon maybe
um I think only the data we had uh we
usually kept talking about the
corporations of hondura because I think
the president of France is already is
always listed as one of the
of this position pretty much
wait a minute so what happens in Andorra
um one of the quote unquote co-princess
of Andorra is the president of France
and the other one I think it's a bishop
yeah from Spain
well
there are lots of different things that
will happen yep
um
so in that case usually what we did
earlier data was that the end start and
end of the tenure is stored in the
information of the tenure itself for
this person that's how we usually handle
to have many people in uh in the same
position
so like for instance a military Junta
many people many generals so to speak
they all have different started end date
pretty much
yeah
right but but so the basic pointers in
in these cases
it is you just have multiple people who
all
I mean there's a different entity for
each tenure so to speak and a tenure
includes both the position and dates and
the person
yes
so that doesn't seem problematic so I'm
I'm retracting my complaints about
co-ceos
I mean it is a little weird
that
it's like
you know in most I mean just wait until
we have to represent holocracies
you know this idea of having an
organization where instead of a
hierarchical organization it's a
collection of intersecting Circles of
responsibility
ah
I believe uh Zappos the shoe company had
it set up had itself set up that way for
a while
oh my gosh you're right and there's some
blockchain companies as well indeed
indeed
uh
I think holocracies don't get to be
represented much
uh I mean in any way we probably are
going to have the data on them
so okay well let's see what else should
we make sure to figure out here
I think this is probably good feedback
for now I think they're just before we
are seated with fleshing out some more
properties and just bringing more data
in here and aligning people and working
on the company side of this I think
that's good I mean if this is
generally seem sensible then there's
more we can we can go ahead and get in
quickly and come back and talk about
some of that company the company stuff
will be useful to have another
conversation soon because that's where
we get into uh
some of the things we started off with
the the specific versus General types of
positions and how we're representing and
querying for things sorry okay I mean
the other issue is the org charts of
like let's say the US government or
something like this
which we have not discussed here like
what is the position reporting to a
given position
correct I mean I'm not sure we're in a
we are in a position to want to go too
far down anybody's org chart
right now
yeah but also there's this horrifying
you know Matrix management type thing of
people who are
you know could get very messy right
okay
all right
well good okay
some great some progress so we can we
can kick off and move a little quicker
on some building out some more of this
looks good to me great all right see all
thanks to folks on live stream see you
all
bye